fondée en septembre 2020 par le docteur
margulies ce nouveau centre souhaite
prévenir les effets du vieillissement
autant que possible il offre alors aux
patients un suivi selon quatre axes
nutritionnelle psychologique locomoteur
et morphologiques en fait ça fait
vraiment un centre
pluridisciplinaire parce que on parle
vraiment de tout que j'ai pris mon
premier rendez vous il ya un an et demi
dans le vide et au départ c'était
vraiment une par observation pour un
rendez vous sur l'alimentation le
principe de la médecine intégrative
regrouper plusieurs experts en un même
lieu médecin coach sportif
micronutritionniste ou encore
hypnothérapeute ces derniers des
finissants suit un parcours de soins
avec le patient selon ses besoins
le docteur margulies me confiner
patients une fois qu'il les a reçus sur
une première consultation
quand il détecte une problématique
émotionnel ça peut être une
problématique de dismorphophobie c'est à
dire que la la personne ne soient pas
tels cas les signaux nice morpho fomi la
patiente où le patient sera toujours
insatisfait disposant de huit salles de
soins ce centre possède plusieurs
machines pour traiter différents aspects
du corps par exemple la cryolipolyse
médical permet de refroidir de manière
intense un amas graisseux sur les
cuisses et les hanches le ventre ou les
bras le site est également pourvue d'une
machine de l'aide thérapie
c'est un programme pour renforcer la
circulation micro capillaire donc il
peut aider par exemple dans des
problèmes derrick rose de couperose du
visage donc c'est un prof un programme
qui va flasher qui va cas pour but de
renforcer la microcirculation que les
petits capillaires les petits vaisseaux
qui peuvent être dilater dans certaines
pathologies problématique de pau la
médecine intégrative s'installe peu à
peu dans les yvelines un autre centre a
ouvert ses portes à montigny le
bretonneux